apple était le faire ses annonces pour
sa d'abbadia belle d'ici 2022 ces
grosses annonces logiciel or il ya eu
une annonce nous on a senti tout de
suite sur ios parce que c'est le truc
qui m'intéresse eyeos nouvelle version
avec des tout super intéressant et
surtout le truc qui est vraiment
vraiment vraiment vraiment top c'est
toute la partie écran lorsque vous êtes
sur votre écran regardez-vous le monde
le jour le communiqué de presse en même
temps apple dévoile expérience unique
d'un nouvel écran verrouillé ça c'est ça
vachement intéressant pour ios 16 et des
nouveaux moyens de partager et de
communiquer alors le truc qui va
vraiment moi bien intéresser ici c'est
qu'en fait et ça c'est vraiment la
grosse nouveauté le gros nouveau truc
niveau design c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu'on est un espèce de
matériel young qui était présenté sur
android 12 l'année dernière qu'on ait
retrouvé un peu c'est dans l'idée dans
l'esprit c'est à dire que en fait
regardez ici vous allez pouvoir venir
plus tôt misé votre écran de
verrouillage changer la police changer
la couleur change et les font venir les
personnaliser le truc qui a attrait sens
lorsqu'on fait une photo en mode
portrait et bien regardez ça va venir
vous l'a détaché vous faire mettre votre
heure derrière donc ça c'est cool il ya
plein d'autres trucs aux sites ont été
présentés à savoir par exemple d ici en
bas une petite info de notification
lorsque vous avez commandé un hubert
vous voyez où est ce qu'il en est par
rapport au moment où il va arriver chez
vous il ya plein de petites choses
voiliers qui ont été super malines qui
ont été ajoutés ici alors vous avez
plein de widgets pour en mettre 3 je
crois que c'est ce qui nous montre là un
an 4 carrément par m 4 ici donc vous
choisissez dans votre liste de widgets
vous allez voir votre activité la météo
votre niveau de batterie par exemple de
volet repose votre calendrier pas mal de
petites choses que pourra venir se
ranger directement ici vous avez du
choix donc là c'est plutôt cool
a priori à d'autres images fait devant
là alors gardez ça nous montre comme ça
ça vient se mettre par dessus votre
photo dans tout ça vachement jolie et
c'est cool parce que ça prend vraiment
un vent de fraîcheur à ce qu'on avait
sur l'écran de verrouillage avant
c'était plutôt pas l'un des cantons
voisins ont dit ah ouais pourquoi ils
l'ont pas fait plus tôt c'était quand
même vachement cool de la même année à
vous bien choisir la couleur de votre
peau lisse vous venez choisir votre
police également prévenir le changer
donc c'est plutôt cool et après les
espèces de deux filtres des faits que
pour bien se mettre sur votre photo pour
avoir un truc très uniformiser et je
trouve que l'idée juste hyper hyper
hyper canon toutes vos notifications qui
vont venir se positionner juste en bas
ici là c'est pareil voyez pour venir
mettre un petit un petit suivi
d'activité bon là c'est avec nike
pourquoi pas votre musique vient
remettre votre pochette en grand ici si
vous souhaitez donc bon le truc est pas
mal je vous faussez revient donner un
peu plus de vie un peu plus d'intérêt à
cet écran d'accueil donc je trouve ça
écran de verrouillage pardon excusez moi
je trouve ça hyper hyper hyper canon et
sauf que là tu sont vraiment bien bossé
pareil on vient regroupés ici toutes les
notifications on va pouvoir voir notre
photo évitez de les avoir sur l'eau
comme on les avait actuellement comme ça
c'est tout de suite ce qui fait que
lorsque vous mettiez la photo de
quelqu'un que vous aimez faire avancer
et bien vous la vouliez pas parce que
vous aviez les notifications sur la
tronche là les notifications sont en bas
donc c'est plutôt intéressant alors
après ils ont présenté d'autres trucs au
niveau de la concentration donc bon ça
c'est plutôt pas mal d'autres modes de
concentration ou caisse a évolué why not
ça c'est marrant c'est la photothèque
vous partagez sur icloud avec vos amis
par exemple votre famille vous dites
maintien on a tous participé à une
grande réunion de famille tout le monde
a ses photos droite à gauche est bien là
vous venez choisir celles que vous
voulez et vous les partager pour que
tout le monde puisse avoir directement
sur icloud pour ça c'est cool ça évite
d'avoir ainsi envoyé de l'un à l'autre
et c'est ça tout le monde a accès sur un
partage familial je trouve ça vachement
bien il ya également des mises à jour
qui ont été apportées à bessèges bon le
truc qui est intéressant c'est que
lorsque vous avons envoyé un message
vous pouvez venir ici le supprimer ça
c'est plutôt pas mal pour venir
également édité un message alors ça fera
apparaître à la personne ce message a
été modifié
mais si vous êtes trompé que vous avez
un truc qu'il fallait pas à la mauvaise
personne vous pouvez venir les dites et
donc je trouve quand même le truc est
assez rassurant ici il ya également de
nouveaux outils pour mail pour vous le
met ici il est bon on va passer assez
rapidement un truc que je trouve pas mal
me dont le côté un peu trad alors qu'on
peut venir faire également récupérer des
éléments visuels comme ça dans les
vidéos pour le faire dans les photos
pendant pas mal de temps peut bien faire
dans les vidéos ça c'est cool il ya
d'autres que j'ai trouvé bien alors je
sais pas si je venais ici c'est la
dictée vocale ou saveur que vous êtes en
mode dictée vocale et que vous dites est
un texte qui est en train de sa part
être qui est en train d'apparaître
pardon directement sur votre iphone et
bien maintenant je vais pouvoir voir une
combi z'ont bien les garder votre
clavier faire votre dictée vocale avoir
votre clavier donc vous dictez gna gna
gna gna gna gna qu'un poulet gersois
rien par exemple des cendres vous
rajoutez de la ponctuation et le faire
directement avec le texte pourrait le
faire si vous voulez retaper un boutre
point fr reprend la dictée vocale donc
vous voulez vraiment mixer les deux je
trouve ça assez intéressant alors moi je
ne suis pas quelqu'un qui utilise
beaucoup et dictée vocale mais j'en
connais qui l'utilisent pas mal l'idée
d'avoir un peu ce mix dictée clavier je
trouve que ça a un sens c'est que c'est
plutôt intéressant ça plutôt bien mais
moi ce que vous en pensez un embarras
commentaire est ce que vous vous
utilisez le dictée vocale ou alors
absolument pas autant que j'ai trouvé
assez marrant là par exemple voyez une
photo avec un chien ça vous aura pas
échappé et d'impôts et venir faire un
copier du chien vous appuyez vous faire
un copier du chien vous récupérez la
photo du chien et vous pouvez venir la
coller ensuite directement dans un
message pour l'envoyer à des amis ici et
ça tiens regarde mon chien je t'envoie
la photo tiens j'ai trouvé ça marrant je
te l'envoie j'en sais rien ça a vraiment
un sens mais on voit de nouveaux usages
qu'ils n'existaient pas donc je trouve
ça assez rigolo un autre truc qui est
assez marrant au niveau d'apple plaît
ils ont créé un truc qui s'appelle apple
player ça veut dire en fait c'est de la
paye plus la pulp et où julia river où
vous allez payer plus tard alors le
détail il est noté juste là en fait avec
ce truc là je l'aimé où je sais plus je
suis tellement en fait de pouvoir payer
jusqu en quatre paiements différés
différé sur quoi sur six semaines je
crois enfin le truc est pas mal je les
notaires les noter sur le même truc
quand on cherche on ne trouve pas
les noter je sais plus où donc vous
allez pouvoir avoir plusieurs paiements
fractionnés par exemple vous voulez
venir acheter un truc avec help help et
et ça vous coûte un peu cher et bien
vous pouvez le payer en différentes
mensualités directement dans apple paix
dont ça se trouve ça plutôt pas mal et
assez assez intéressant vous voyez par
exemple la voyez hop là quatre paiements
sur six semaines vous payer 15 jours à 1
mois et ensuite à un mois et demi et ça
peut être pas mal pour venir aider les
personnes qui peuvent qui veulent
acheter un cochonnet qu'apple play avec
apple time et qui ne peuvent pas tout
payer d'un seul coup pourquoi pas ehsan
et vous n'avez absolument plus s'cusez
moi aucun frais là dessus donc ça c'est
plutôt pas mal il ya un autre qu'ils ont
présenté ces deux-là pulp et directement
de smartphone à smartphone l'iphone
iphone au contact en fait vous les
prenez vous les posez et vous avez le
paiement qui se fait d'un iphone à notre
iphone alors ça peut être marrant entre
potes lorsque vous voulez venir vous
envoyer de l'argent pourquoi pas il ya
dire différentes solutions qui existent
comme ça le truc qui est pas mal c'est
que si vous êtes commerçant et que vous
avez un iphone et que vous voulez pas
prendre une tp avec votre banque ou un
seul peuple et compagnie vous pouvez
faire payer directement avec votre
iphone or il faut qu'un iphone sans
attention vos clients et un iphone mais
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas je trouve ça
assez marrant alors je ne sais pas si ça
peut être vraiment intéressant il faut
quand même des clients qui beaucoup
d'iphone mais dans l'idée why not alors
voyez après il ya plein de nouvelles
choses ça c'est un truc vachement ip je
pense qu'on n'en parlera plus tard c'est
une nouvelle génération de cartes plaît
car plaît vous savez c'est l'expérience
dans les automobiles vous avez
l'expérience apple apple car plein on a
déjà parlé je vous ai déjà présenté et
là ils sont dit ok il ya un constat les
écrans prennent de plus en plus de place
dans les véhicules donc nous et parce
que qu'est ce qu'on va faire eh bien on
va venir augmenter l'expérience et sa
part des trucs dingues comme ça je
trouve ça absolument dingue c'est apple
car pelé tout ça c'est apple car play
est en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
apple car plus il va communiquer avec la
voiture il ya des informations de la
voiture qu'ils vont remonter dans apple
car play et de la même manière vous
pourrez venir un personnaliser votre
écran de verrouillage de votre iphone et
bien s il voulait pouvoir dire
complètement personnalisé apple car play
choisir l'écran soit avoir une petite
aiguille soit avoir un compteur digital
choisir la couleur choisir les
différentes applications via un widget
qui vont venir sa fiche et alors là
c'est très très grand ce convoi
attention mais on va pouvoir aller loin
par mir customiser je trouve que ça
c'est aussi génial et c'est vraiment une
façon de venir tous stomisés
l'expérience apple iphone apple car
plaît donc ça s'est une fois de plus
super super cool alors après il ya eu
plein de trucs il ya apple plan il y
avait une belle mise à jouer dernière on
n'avait pas profité nous en france on
vend profité cette année donc ça c'est
plutôt cool le partage familial la
dictée je venais à part les favoris et
il ya plein de choses intéressantes
également l'application en maison qui a
évolué avec je dirais une interface plus
sympa tous classés par pièce par espace
comme ça plutôt pas mal alors après il
ya plein d'autres choses on en reparlera
une prochaine fois pour moi ici le truc
qui est vraiment vraiment vraiment
vraiment c'est cette grosse mise à jour
de customisation soit votre écran de
verrouillage c'est pour moi la grosse
mise à jour qu'il fallait faire et apple
l'a fait bonjour ça vachement cool il ya
eu plein de choses intéressantes il ya
peu de grosses annonces produits si ce
n'est macbook air et macbook pro 13
pouces avec la nouvelle puce m2 mais
tout ça on en reparlera bientôt c'est
les produits qu'on regardera contestera
donc je vous invite à faire une chose
c'est à venir vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà fait et vous allez voir ce taux
que l'on va venir les tester en direct
et ses nouvelles fonctionnalités dès
qu'elles seront dispo parce que ça me
plaît bien sûr c'est intéressant ça va
dans le sens de l'histoire alors après à
côté de ça j'étais un peu frustré un
moment parce que je dis ok ok il nous
présente deux nouveaux fonds d'écran on
voit la planète terre et quand on rentre
dessus on voit hopla komm scénario sur
la planète c'est pas nouveau j'ai déjà
vu chez shiomi sur me why je sais plus
quelle version bilingue ça j'ai déjà vu
donc à des choses qui viennent mettre en
place doit y ait toujours un peu cette
idée de personnalisation un peu à la
matérialité ou sur android 12 beau ça
avance il ya des choses où ils viennent
se met à jour et des choses où ils
viennent vraiment innové en tout cas
l'expérience de trucs cool je trouve
intéressante à de la tester hâte de la
découvrir et hâte de la mettre dans mon
iphone vous savez le cool dites moi vous
quelle est la fonctionnalité qui vous a
le plus intéressé celle que vous avez
envie d'intégrer dans votre iphone est
ce que vous êtes hype et parce qu'ils
étaient présentes et où est ce que j'ai
plutôt un peu mitigé un peu un peu
frileux jean sarrailh envers marc et moi
tout ça en bas en commentaire on en
reparle très bientôt pascal plein de
jolies s'annonce ipad ios mac os plein
de trucs dont tous on en parle très très
bientôt je vous embrasse prenez soin de
vous et à bientôt chao des bisous bisous
bisous